Hey everyone. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab,
the podcast.
Robert and I are about to go on tour
literally in a few hours to la in Seattle.
Yep. But before we do, um,
we leave you with a, um,
well why don't you set it
up? Well this is just a,
one of those crazy and wonderful
conversations that just popped into being.
Uh,
one of my favorite books of the last
couple of years was a book called the age
of wonder.
It was written by Richard Holmes and it
describes a particular group of people,
a bunch of people who kind of invented
modern science sort of together in the
1780s, the 1790s in the early 18 hundreds.
A crazy and wonderful group.
Balloonists and explorers and astronomers
who believed that the world was full
of miracles and surprising rules that
could be detected if you looked hard and
experiment an experimentation
was your thing.
Anyway,
I was talking to Mr. Holmes about his
book and move a little to the left,
why he wrote it and how it
all came to being a move.
That just a bit full him down and
begin the conversation by mentioning
somebody's name. It's
Yvonne East Gullah if at least the guys
was so like what happened to you? Okay.
That's a great, great story.
It's to do with how I fell into
writing science after literature.
There are various reasons for this. Um,
I had it when I go a lot scientific
childhood, which we weren't going to now,
but in fact as a,
as a kid I was fascinated by science
and because of the the Wade literature
literature. Yeah, the
education is sort of streamed.
I was taken away from that as
a kid. I could build radios,
I could strip motorcycle engine. Actually
Modelez you were one of the things,
I was one of those and I had a wonderful
uncle in the Royal Air Force who taught
me a lot about fight and
actually I can now set once,
smuggle me in to a v Boma and
atomic bama. I have to say,
we didn't take over. There were
bombs. It was [inaudible]. It was,
it was one of those Big v bombers
that could carry smuggled,
doing it in a nice way as a tourist.
Or he thought he was going to drop
you out of state. Yeah, no, he saw it.
He thought, H, here's the kid.
Let's educate him. Say, took me in.
He showed me how it worked.
Sat me in the copilot seat.
We were still on the ground. We was not.
Um, and then he smuggled me out again.
I've never forgotten
it. It was under a coat.
Now you just said it was
the same as on the parkway.
It was his plane after had his name on
it. He was the pilot. Okay. And he's a,
I denied what he said to the engineer.
I would just take, take my nephew in,
you know? Yeah. So, so I
had that last interview,
which all began to come back when I
started work on their magic scientists.
I also had this amazing braking. We're
getting into, everybody's got one now.
I was given what they call a visiting
fellowship at Trinity College, Cambridge.
That's Cambridge, England. This is
Newton's college or it Barron's college.
It's famous for its scientists,
among other things, astrophysics,
particularly in mathematics.
And one you're invited
as a writer about poets.
You've been now writing
biographies and books about side.
And I was meant to be doing
research thing on biography,
the history of bog literary biography.
And what actually happened was I found
these wonderful scientific archives,
particularly the letters of Hash
or that kept there in Cambridge.
And I started reading this. He's talking
about William and Caroline Herschel.
This is a brother and sister team that
did build big telescopes and meet all
kinds of fascinating discoveries about
stars and planets in those days. And uh,
and gradually I was drawn.
I thought this is absolutely
wonderful and there's all this,
this last side of me started
fading back plus, uh,
at trinity there's this tradition,
they talk about the high table.
It's actually very democratic.
You go in every evening to
have a very rapid dinner,
but you sit next to whoever happens to
be there. There's no system of seating.
Okay. So this is you and all the other
teachers? This is, no, this is all the,
the senior research faculty and so
on. Okay. So these are people of imp,
Beazer Wiki people. There were
seven Nobel prize winners. Okay.
And I sat next to each of them
at various points. All right.
And as this is one of these long tables
where every plate is set that Friday and
every knife is perfectly exactly
right. Formal way form of silverware,
jugs of water and sound.
And you talk basically the person on
your left or your right and you have to
talk fast because they
don't, we imagine, you know,
these don't sit around
bruising. They don't,
that I think I've really noticed the
meal would probably be over in about 25
minutes. Amazing. Okay. And you
talked, and once you got talking,
I often never had time to finish my meal
because it was, I would sit next to,
I'd be next to an astrophysicist.
And the famous thing I, which for me,
this was something that
for you at this point,
like you were just
laughing and he was, yes,
I mean I was absolutely riveted and I
found things like scientists love to
discuss their science. They're very
often very good at describing it,
which I loved compared with some of the
literary Don's you know God and you're
going to literary theory and these guys
want you to understand. And I love that.
On this particular occasion I sat down
too next to a man who became clear a that
he was Russian and he spoke
no English at all. And B,
that he was a mathematician.
Okay. About which, you know,
which I knew very little.
I was trying to learn a bit to catch
up with the hurdles. Very, very little.
So I thought, I cannot let this pass.
There's no possibility of communication,
but come on. The math and common
or the language. Yes. Okay.
So I think about this for a moment and
in studying beginning to tell you this
period,
I have indeed been looking
at the mathematicians of
this period and the French
mathematicians of this period
are where the cutting edge is.
And there's one particular thing
what the 1790 years at exactly Jim,
particularly during the
French revolution, right.
And there's a young mathematician
whose name was ever east gala,
at least gala itself is music
to my ears. And, and he lived,
his life was a short, as a romantic poet.
He from at school, he was
at least a little, the,
I think got thrown out of almost
every institution he was in.
But he had a natural gift for
mathematics, theoretical mathematics.
And he also was
politically rather radical.
And to cut the story short in
a row, I've got the exact date,
but maybe about roundabout age
and 20, something like that. Um,
he was writing on the theory
of mathematics number theory
in a more advanced way
than anybody could understand.
He sent in papers to the academy and
they were sent at the age of 19. Yes,
19 2021 he was okay. And then he was
developing a theory which will come to,
which he got involved in. We're not
quite sure if it was a political thing,
but it involved a deal he was challenged
to do and we think it was over a young
woman as so many Jews are,
if you're 1819 or 20 and he is summoned
out to have this June in the borderline
and the night before this deal he sits
down and he writes a mathematical paper.
He puts in everything he knows into
the single paper and it's very moving.
I've seen the manuscript, I have
some grasp of what's going on,
but it's also that there are
lines of poetry in it that lines,
which are clearly about this girl.
We don't acquire what we
don't know what her name was.
And the repeated thing is I have no time.
I have no time. There is no time.
So he's cramming this all in until
dawn. It's unbelievable situation.
This paper and the math is in there
too. And the masters in that too. Okay.
And he, he completes the Syrian.
We'll come to this in a moment. Uh,
and then he goes out
and he shot and he dies
and this paper is left on his desk
and he's a great friend, saves it.
And it's published about, I
think about 20 years later,
the math bits or maths and the
love stuff, not the love stuff.
Um, and it's the beginning of
a stage, a mathematical theory,
which is called groups.
Every group theory right now,
this much I knew and very, very broadly,
here's my analogy to what groups
here is a very, very dangerous, uh,
it's to do with certain kinds
of equation. All right? That,
you know those things with an
equal sign and Ab and, yeah. Okay.
It involves what they call cubix.
So when something has x
to the power of three,
it's a particular form of equation,
which will, you cannot work it,
it will not produce the result.
It will when it's square,
but not when it's cubed or when it's,
what would it call four times in Sonic?
So it's a temperamental,
it is a temperamental equation and no
mathematics and had found a way of solving
it at the higher power. All right,
so the analogy is it's like a box,
which when it reaches a certain size,
you can't act in it anymore.
Okay. Now group theory will be v,
this is my fashion of it, which
I had vaguely come to understand.
It's like you kind of open that box.
So what you do is you put that box
inside a bigger box and you can open the
bigger box and that somehow lets
you into the little one. Oh, okay.
I can't take you further
than that. Okay. Right.
So back to the Russian mathematician.
So I turned to him as it were,
with the soup thing still in my hand.
And I said every gala means you just
needed to start the conversations. Right.
That's the only thing
I could think of doing.
I could just blurted out the name of a
19 year old ancient French mathematician,
Nutso, ancient romantic
French mathematician.
I looked him dead between the eyes.
I said every gala and there
was a pause and to this day,
this wonderful thing,
he looked at me and this sort
of seraphic green plastic face.
And then he did this gesture,
which you cannot see being radio,
which is so visual, but what it is,
his right hand went over his heart as
if he was saluting the flag. All right.
And then both hands went out,
was in a big embracing gesture.
And what he was saying to me to start,
it was every Skylar's so dear to
my heart and to any mathematician.
Alright. And then the big gesture
meant he invented group theory. Okay.
And then he looked at me and then the
smile got bigger and then he leaned across
the table and he pulled in all the
Crockery, the silver water jug,
the knife, the fort, the plates.
And he showed me group theory of what I
tried to explain to you the little box
inside the big box in
terms of the knife spoons,
played salts,
no words, no words. There was no way.
I knew he was talking about groups theory
and that's how he explained it to me.
So if I hear the sound first of
a hand gun. Yes, that's right.
I hear the clanking of silver. Well,
there's this wonderful gesture which can
cause, right? The broad gestures. Yes.
And in wonderful way.
And it's very trinity this none
of the other dance turn her hair.
She's dragging all the crockery over and
things, you know? Yes, yes. Of course.
You know, what else would we expect?
And there he is explaining to and giving
this model that I've tried to explain
on air as the little box you can't
open, you put it in a bigger box.
[inaudible] position was
10 minutes long. Okay.
Well it couldn't be more than 25
because the dinners never lasted more.
I think that was one of the days
identically I ate anything from the thing.
I think I had a glass of water.
Maybe I had a glass of wine
probably to keep myself going.
But that whole conversation
took place wordlessly yes.
And I say that for sort
of the period of time,
that 20 minutes I sort of understood
group's area because he somehow,
the way he did it, I thought, Oh yes.
Okay. It's that. It's that, it's that.
And to me it was kind
of, it was a one off.
It was a sort of revelation
moment really. And I thought,
I love you science people that
you won't, nothing will stop you.
You or Jaguar going to explain
this. And also I thought, you know,
here I am sitting at one of the great
universities with this chance to learn,
okay and learn a new
field and said, this guy,
this wonderful rush method, he's
done this to me. I am now going to,
I work at this and try and
produce, I know this is a big leap,
but it was in my mind,
I would try and write a book that
was somehow do the same thing.
I didn't know how the hell I'm
going to do this at this time. Okay.
I don't know enough sense
some, but I'll work at it.
And that's how he got to
right. The age of wonder,
which was the best book of the year from
the National Academies of science and
Engineering, whatever the other one
is. It's it and it's uh, is such a,
Oh man. I mean, it was kind of an
adventure story. It's an adventure. Great.
Yeah. Anyways, so that's Richard Holmes,
and I guess that's the vodcast. Uh,
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Roberta
quilvent. Thanks for listening.